we know you like things done a certain
way Abby Lee Miller but would it really
be so bad to eat up on your junior
students we know you're preparing them
for the real world but sometimes you go
a little too far okay let's be honest do
you take things too far all the time
some of your former students refuse to
talk to you while others still call you
up to go on lunch dates
there's just no in-between say what you
will about Abby but she's still the best
in the business who say that Abby takes
things too far would be an
understatement watch until the end to
find out why Mia and Cameron are having
a hard time forgiving Abby for her
outrageous comments the cover-up Abby
Lee Miller says the meanest things and
sometimes her words are just too cruel
to showcase Dance Moms is notorious for
censoring their content and creating
fake scenarios and this is exactly what
happened during the season 4 finale the
editors reused footage of a be telling
Kristen but in reality Abby made fun of
Chloe's medical condition telling her to
go fix her eye even the producers of the
show knew that Abby had gone too far
which is why they edited the clip in her
favor
sticks and stones if there's one thing
that puts Abby in a sour mood it's
losing but her mood only intensifies
when she loses to her rival Cathy from
the candy apples Dance Center this is
exactly what happened in season 5
episode 13 after beating the ALDC Cathy
and her dancers entered Abby's changing
room to gloat Cathy was holding the cake
with Abby's face on it and Abby wanted
none of it on her way out of the room
Abby whispered get those ears fixed to
one of Cathy's dancers while we
understand that she was upset Abby took
things way too far when she insulted an
innocent and talented young dancer not
smart enough in season 5 Abby insulted
Mackenzie's intelligence in front of the
entire oh gee squad the pressure was on
and Kenzie was having a hard time
remembering her solo Kenzie was nearly
in tears when she told Abby that maybe
she was thinking too much
that's when Abby took things a step
further and told her
she even questioned Melissa about
whether or not homeschooling was a good
choice for her youngest daughter
judgmental and rude
Abby is known for her outbursts and
taking her frustrations out on others
and this is exactly what she did to
Melissa in season 3 episode 5 Abby yells
at Melissa in front of her children
causing them to cry she tells Melissa
and she even scolds Melissa for getting
divorced and finding someone new
Abby had no place talking about
Melissa's personal life in front of the
entire gang suck it up if there's one
thing Abby hates it's crying children
she puts a lot of pressure on her
students and more often than not they
break a lot of Abby students have had
panic attacks in her studio but
obviously Abby doesn't know the
difference between tears and panic
attacks Kindle was showing clear signs
of a panic attack in season 4 episode 13
but Abby brushed it off panic attacks
are very real and terrifying and a dance
teacher who takes care of children
should know how to handle them the chair
thro the Highlands never had it easy
with Abby but some would agree that
Kelly brought it upon herself in season
two kelly highlands got into a fight
with Abby because she forgot to put
stoppers on her daughter Paige's chair
Abbey threw the chair in front of Paige
making her feel totally uncomfortable
and then tried to pin Paige against her
mother
all in all Abby took things too far and
Kelly helped her get there all washed up
in season 2 Abby and Christi faced off
in the competition changing rooms and
things get ugly fast
Abby calls Chloe a snake and goes on to
tell Christine that her daughter will be
all washed up in five years and if that
wasn't bad enough Abby said this in
front of Chloe making her cry there's
always a favorite Abby had to learn the
hard way that plain favorites is a
recipe for disaster all the moms pay
Abby the same amount of money so she
should focus on all of her dancers
instead of just one Abby took things to
a whole new level by playing favorites
with Maddie
Kalani Brynn and Brady and choosing to
ignore dancers like Paige Nia Chloe and
Presley offensive comments it's a
well-known fact that Abby wants her
dancers to have neat hair which is why
Holly made sure to get approval for
Nia's hair when she had graded
extensions put in so when Holly
challenged Abby in season 2 episode 20
Abby chose to retaliates by making fun
of Nia's hair Holly and Nia were
rightfully upset over Abby's offensive
comments more offensive comments Abby
doesn't have a filter and on more than
one account Nia and Cameron have self at
Abby's comments were borderline racist
Kamryn bridges revealed that Abby
commented about her skin color and how
the bottom of her feet were lighter than
the rest of her body
Abby's comments made Cameron feel super
uncomfortable and it's not hard to see
why do you think Abby should change her
attitude or are her rude ways would make
Dance Moms so entertaining sound off in
the comments and thanks for watching hit
that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up we'll see you next
time on the things
[Music]